all right nancy hi nancy where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
well i was born in west by god virginia
we say
which part um town called parkersburg oh
yeah up north yeah it's right on the
ohio river
and you know very uh
very cool place to be born you know it's
uh
from what i hear whaling which is just
down the street is like was voted safest
place to live in america
so you know grow up and lock your doors
or whatever but
unfortunately
just because it's voted the safest
doesn't mean you know things are always
like that you know like i was just
mentioning my my older brother was
murdered
but right in front of my younger brother
at a party at a cake party by my
sister's boyfriend you mean so it's
that was
that was the
craziness you know and he just
was your family like
um
crazy i'm actually the
only child of
my parents however i have stepsisters
that brothers adopted and such um but
technically i'm an only child my father
passed away when i was like four years
old
my mother's first husband passed away
um my sisters were four two in six
months so then she met my father
and ironically they were born on the
same day my father and the sister that
was six months old right
so
he was around until i was four he was
actually murdered
he was a police officer and his high
school sweetheart
was married to the chief of police's
nephew okay
and um i guess he was beating her or
something like that so you know
my dad and her high school sweethearts
she calls him up whenever he gets above
the man murdered her and um
so my dad
was trying to intervene in something i
guess he got you know he got laid off
suspended or whatever from the force um
and eventually he ended up dead
with uh they said he fell off the back
of the pickup truck and he was loading
hay helping a friend but you know his
head was was crushed you know so
uh many years later when i was like
40 ish something like that ironically i
was at my mom's house and
the nurse that
was there the night of that he was
brought in
was on her deathbed
and her name was ironically nancy too
but she wanted to call my mom and let my
mom know that he was murdered and that
um
she was sworn to secrecy because uh
you know they wanted covered up you know
and
she said that everybody who was involved
with that has now passed away and that
she was on her deathbed and she couldn't
go without letting my mom know that
and it was crazy because i just so
happened to be there and i answered the
phone when she called
you know i hadn't been there in seven
years or something like that
so
it's it's um you know
vindicating on the level that you know i
knew it you know kind of thing but
at the same time still you know i lost
my father so west virginia is
crazy isn't it it's crazy yeah you know
it really is because everybody's toting
guns and you know living how they live
and
you know there's not a lot of uh
policing done you know the sheriffs all
know you by first name and stuff so you
know it's a lot different than l.a
so how would you describe your childhood
in general um well like i said my father
was um
the second husband my mom had lost so
she was a little
um
estranged i guess she wasn't there
emotionally
um
you know granted you know she just went
through this twice and she felt like she
was a jinx so she marries this
guy who actually ended up being my first
cocaine connection when i was 13.
and uh
he just did a lot of drugs and and ran
around and
cheated on my mother a lot he actually
took a life insurance policy out on her
and had her run off the road on the
motorcycle
crazy things like that just a lot of
insanity so
eventually by the time i was about
12
my mom met
the man who raised me from that point on
if you want to say raised but he was
there he's the father figure from that
point on um
uh
yeah so at 13 though
he was a i'm sorry let me back up he was
a
traveling insulator so he insulated
nuclear plants all around the country
right
so he was always on the road she wanted
to be with him he made her happy you
know i mean she just wanted to be happy
of course you know and she left my
me and my 17 year old sister together in
her home
now
right about this time
i had actually
gained my first
stalker first person who stalked me
turned out to be a serial killer he was
a cross-country killer they
killed him on death row in 2014.
tommen cells
was his name
uh he said he stopped counting at 80
people what was his name tommy lee tommy
lynn sells
s-e-l-o-s
um
yeah he
hop trains
train hop so he went you know all over
the country killing people he broke in
my home he was actually my mom had two
houses on a property
the back house no one's supposed to be
living in there
my bedroom actually faced the back house
so
no one was there i didn't keep my
windows closed nothing you know
lights on whatever so um
one night
my boyfriend and all my friends went out
they went on a beer run or something
because the town we lived in was dry so
they had to go up just up the road to
get beer
he forgot his id
and so he came back
but in the meantime
this man had broken into my house he was
in my bedroom i went upstairs and he
just attacked me you know the first time
i spoke with him
i said oh sh you scared me because he
ran up on me and he's like that's not
what i intend to do to you
um
i was like oh so i ran
ran to my friend's house and
he
stopped me from then on um where'd he
meet you first
um
he just he was on just saw me walking
because i would walk across the train
tracks over the hill oh so he didn't
know you at all didn't know me at all
and um just ran up on me one day and i
said oh you scared me
and he said well that's not what i
intend to do to you so i just booked it
i took off running because i would pick
up my girlfriend and we would walk to
school together so i just ran to her
house and
just basically stayed inside until he
left me but he waited outside for us for
a half hour 45 minutes something like
that
the police told us to take another route
to school
they can't do anything until he touches
me
so eventually he does he breaks in he
had
had my mom's back house he had chairs
facing my bedroom he was smoking the
same brand of cigarettes so he came back
yeah he was like watching me from from
the back house and had no idea
so
when he broke in and attacked me um
it was crazy my boyfriend happened to
come back
he jumped out the window second story
window he jumped out the window and was
on went back to the back house and was
on the balcony and back house watching
my boyfriend talk to the police because
my boyfriend called the police
and he was like who the hell is that and
of course
we were going in from one way he was
exiting another way he got away he got
away from my mom three separate
occasions she's chasing him down in the
vehicle and he would just
pop a fence or hop you know whatever hop
on a train and he was gone
he got away every time but um eventually
he was caught because in texas he
killed this whole he slaughtered the
whole family but the little the daughter
she survived he had slit her throat she
ran like
a mile or quarter mile or something with
her throat slit
and uh called police and they caught him
in the act that's how he finally got
caught
yeah so that was
he murdered his wife his son his
stepfather
um
yeah he was just crazy i guess he did a
lot of drugs and he was a carney
did whatever but you were so lucky i was
very fortunate very very fortunate um
and needless to say that's not the first
serial killer i've encountered
uh in florida because i moved to florida
when i was you know we lived back and
forth my younger years but i ended up
going to school and stuff in in fort
lauderdale so
like i said my mother had left me at age
13 um by the time i'm running the
streets doing you know whatever i got to
do to survive
you know and i was just streaking at
that point but i still went to school
you know i mean i still knew that that
was important you know i needed to do
that
so
on weekends um we would go down to the
strip fort lauderdale strip and all of
us would hang out there was like you
know 10 15 of us you know we know it's
hangout young kids you know ages you
know 13 to 18 or something like that
um
but yeah one day you know doing what i
have to do to survive i jump in the car
with this guy and um
i don't know i can't remember exactly
what he said or what he did oh i
remember
he didn't have the to pull the locks on
the door
there weren't any on the doors and the
door was locked i was like oh my god
there's some there's red flag you know
red like immediately so i just kind of
like did this number and like
i by the grace of god i got it unlocked
and i jumped out of the red light but he
killed four girls that week i mean that
weekend
really yeah but he was caught right away
that you you were working the streets as
a prostitute yeah
yeah
so yeah so eventually you got into
dancing yeah eventually um i
got a gig modeling lingerie and
swimsuits and i was 14.
um
but it was called chantelli lace is the
name of the company um
we went around to bars and sold tickets
for the lingerie and i got modeled like
five outfits whatever
um people would raffle it off or you
know raffle tickets and they'd raffle
and when when the outfit that i was
wearing or whatever
and
she also did uh
runway shows you know she did things
like that also so i started doing that
and eventually that led me into
stripping you know um i started working
for the
um there's a chain of gentlemen's clubs
hi and gentlemen club
they had the doll houses pure platinum
and solid gold i worked at solid gold
because it was not fully nude it was uh
we had to wear pasties
on our breasts but we were just strings
and we gave lap dances right
if you were fully nude you could not
touch the customer at all you had to be
on a table with your knees together and
i was i for whatever reason at that
point in time i was too shy to go fully
nude so
i thought that was a little safer route
this is west virginia or florida no this
is in florida just in fort lauderdale um
yeah because i moved down by this time i
moved
down there and uh
yeah so i was too chicken [ __ ] to to do
it fully nude so i went with the
you know
bikini route
but it was cool it was a lot of fun they
made a lot of money a lot of you know
met a lot of nice people good people
rich people you know we would go out and
they had their own yacht we would go out
and do little cruises through the
through the bay you know showing off and
promoting the club and doing all that
stuff which was a lot of fun you know
it's it's very flattering you know
especially when you're a young girl you
know it's like you get a lot of it is it
is that and i was underage too well you
were yeah i was under age
they didn't know that at a time but they
didn't check too hard either
you know that was
the steam building doing that kind of
work for you for me it was yeah i liked
it i i enjoyed the attention i enjoy the
money of course um
yeah i like it i don't have a problem
with it i've never been embarrassed by
it i've never had you know any issue
with it i think that you know
we're doing a lot of good we're making
people happy you know i mean
you know you stand in front of god one
day you know if we get a merit for
how much pleasure we brought people in
the world you know as opposed to pain i
think i'll be pretty much up there on
this scale that's a great way of looking
at it yeah you know so i mean how can it
be wrong you're being you're we're grown
adults well
grown adults but uh two adults
consenting to make each other happy god
made it to feel good so it should feel
good right so what's wrong with that
you know
i think monogamy is
maybe a good idea for some people
but it's not realistic i mean you can't
expect somebody to just sleep with you
for the rest of their life you know and
not be attracted to anyone else you know
um
that just to me it doesn't doesn't work
it doesn't work for me um
if you can you know and a lot of people
don't understand that
just because
love is love sex and sex and
money is money
in my opinion um
you know just because i love someone
doesn't mean that i'm not attracted to
another person and that i can't have sex
with that person because
i'm in love with this one
you know you love your mother mother and
your father and your siblings it's all
special kind of love right
yeah so i don't know there's not enough
love to go around
have you been married um yeah i have
been married one time um i'm technically
still married uh we never divorced for i
don't know why we never divorced um
i was married for
10 years together
and eventually i caught him and my best
friend
in the bathtub together
and they had been lying to me for like
two years i knew you know i had i also
have a theory that if you sleep with
someone
lying to them those days are over you
mean like
you just you connect in a way that you
just can't lie to that person anymore
um
same thing with your parents we come
from their essence how are you gonna lie
to them they know you know whether they
choose to admit it or believe it
but yeah just lying to them is just
ridiculous you know
is that okay there yeah that's great
okay um
so yeah so i started out you know
stripping for them doll and the
dollhouses and solid gold and eventually
um they asked they offered me to
open up clubs for them across the
country right they were opening up
four clubs five clubs something like
that um
one in clear water
one in dallas texas
and
another in hollywood
no um
it was great i went
to clear water
we uh got stuck there for an extra week
for some reason i'm not sure why
but uh
we had to survive so we
we had to find another strip club
straight brothel it was called venus
something or something or other i walk
in the door and this chicks on stage and
she's literally like squirting breast
milk
across the stage to this guy's mouth
i was
like i was shocked you know i was young
as a young girl i was 18. i'm just like
oh my god where are we at because i had
my friend katrina with me and we we went
together to do these
openings but yeah and it was fully nude
and it was just a straight brothel and
and i mean
they had the back rooms doing everything
there's a lot of
other x-ray extracurricular
that goes on strip clubs right huh
there's a lot of extra activities that
go on a screen clip oh yeah yeah besides
you know
sex and stripping drugs and you know
fighting and drama and you know there's
a lot of sex in the back rooms too right
oh yeah yeah well i mean it depends on
depends on the club it depends on the
club i mean if it's a gentleman's club
they're a little more strict on it
because they you know they're up on
their license and all that kind of stuff
where
a place like that venus place or
whatever uh not so much
um they probably shouldn't even have
been open because it was just yeah on
hygiene alone
it was gnarly so you you were to strip
clubs for how long
um until i was um i started
i s well i got into a car accident when
i was 19.
so um it was kind of short-lived but
um i had a lot of fun doing it i
experienced a lot of things you know i
went to
from cooler from clearwater we went to
dallas which was
amazing it's called fantasy ranch and i
believe it's still open
it's called the fantasy ranch and it had
seven different rooms seven different
stages main stages uh different you know
bdsm
uh
you know um doctor and you know just all
these different fantasies that you know
most people have and so you get to go in
and fit the part you know
and
you know be on the main stage for that
show and then they just did a rotation
you know
but it was also a high end gentleman's
club so we made a lot of money but you
know it was just a gorgeous beautiful
beautiful place you know all the
everything was you know
just top of the line you know
that was the first place i saw
someone get flogged
and it was a big old cowboy and i was
like oh my little girl and she's just in
the bdsm room and she is just letting
him have it with bullet just
and he
oh wow he was screaming and he was like
a big old burly guy you know what i mean
and you would never expect he's on all
fours getting beat you know i mean
it was fun it was good times
but uh yeah so eventually that lid led
me to the hollywood club which when i
got here they decided they weren't going
to open anymore
so here i am california um
what are my options okay
i ended up going to the seventh vail
which another strip club yeah another
strip club they had
the seven fail and then the crazy horse
and crazy horse was topless and seventh
bill was fully new now mind you i have
never you know until venus place never
danced nude at all so i was
really really scared about doing it you
know
but it ended up ha you know a lot of fun
raising hell at the seventh bill you
know and we sure did i mean
the bouncer's name was animal you know
guys wouldn't pay we'd kick beers off
onto them ashtrays whatever you know
kick him
in the face if we wanted to like it was
just crazy and and the bouncer all we'd
have to do
and he would
pick him up by the neck and
escort him out you know
but yeah we had
don't get on that stage and not tip you
know it's not a good idea because you're
going to wear your drink or and the
ashtray you know and be lucky if you
don't get a spike heel
in the face
but yeah so
i worked there and uh
it was really nice the i had
the owners love me they actually gave me
insurance health insurance how many
strippers do you know that have health
insurance
but uh one of the owners he was you know
head over heels for me he would throw a
hundred dollars in singles on the stage
every night to get you know set my night
off and um
yeah it was it was a lot of fun they had
a lot of cheeks that came in because
they were
irani or something like that um so they
would have cheeks to come i mean they
would pay girls ten thousand dollars
just to turn them down
yeah it was crazy they they like the
after hours clubs and or they'd like to
have after hours parties you know i mean
so they would come and do the club and
pick out which girls they wanted and
yeah
pay a girl ten thousand dollars to tell
her oh no you're not up to par or
whatever
you know because they're princes and
they could get anybody they wanted you
know
so they thought anyway so they
enjoyed being rejected
they enjoyed doing the rejection they
enjoyed telling the girl oh
you're not good enough
you're not good enough get out of here
just throw 10 grand at them you know
they did a lot of cocaine they loved you
know but you know that wasn't really my
style because i didn't like they'd like
to humiliate the women you know and i
wasn't down for that you know i think
it's you know it's a beautiful art you
know dancing seeing a beautiful woman
you know
bear
you know it's just it's natural it's
beautiful you know one you know much
more beautiful than that maybe if she's
pregnant maybe
maybe that's the only thing i can think
of but they like to humiliate the girls
and so i hated that part of it but they
treated me so good
i wasn't going to tell them no if they
asked me to go so i would always go and
poor just fortunately i'm personable i
can you know pretty much get along with
most people and so i didn't really ever
have any problems no they weren't really
mean to me but outside of the regular
normal stuff and i saw them be very mean
to a few of the girls a few girls like
you know making them
uh eat something off the floor you know
like just just ridiculously
humiliating these girls and
it's it was just really sad they
actually
paid to have them brought over to their
palace you know they would pay girls to
to go over there but you're basically
they're hostage when you got there
because you couldn't leave you can
associate with anybody you can tell
anybody where you're going um and you
had to stay there like
between 10 to 15 days or something like
that
and do what they want and i'm sure
that they were doing that stuff here
god knows what they were doing over
there to these poor girls i would i
wouldn't go i was i was too afraid to go
i was afraid what they would do
have drugs been a part of your life um
yeah yeah you know um i started doing
cocaine when i was like 13. yeah you
told me that my sister started getting
me high at seven years old with me but i
mean i mean later in your life oh yeah i
mean i've basically continued um
since then i started you know about age
13 with cocaine and i'm graduated to
to speed and then on to heroin
i broke my neck and back when i was 19.
so that basically kicked off my heroin
addiction
i had started already using it
but
that just set it in i after that i did
it every single day um
ever so
it never made me sick unless i didn't
have it so my body just automatically
was like oh you have arrived this is
what you want just what you're craving
but i would always do what they call
goofballs which is methamphetamine and
heroin mixed together
and i did that for
the present day you know i've done that
um i was sober for five years
um
relationship took me out on that one
you know number one
uh reason for going out is relationships
i guess so they say and uh
but yeah um
drugs have always been part of my life
uh
when i was
14 i met my first true love or whatever
i like called him um
he and i sold
lsd we sowed
weed
um coke whatever we could sell you know
i mean so
needless to say i've done a lot of his
acid because we had to check it of
course you know
we had to check it to make sure it was
clean before we sell it
so i've done a lot of hits of acid and i
had a lot of trips and a lot of good
times do you have kids um unfortunately
no
i've been pregnant one time but i'm
miscarried
so i have had custody of my goddaughter
two of them actually um
for approximately five years the last
one
but
her mother actually went and said to the
judge i don't want her but i don't want
her to have her and they took her from
me they took her from me which was just
i couldn't she's lived with me since she
was six months old
so she was five
her mother's boyfriend was molesting her
and they took her out of my care and
just crazy just craziness the way the
system works it's just really crazy and
i haven't heard anything from her since
they wrote me one letter and sent me a
picture of her and said that they put
her on
something ritalin or something because
she was acting out she's out of control
and she just looked completely looped
out in this picture and i was just like
how is that
how is that better i mean she's
obviously acting out because she's never
you know you ripped her out of the only
place she's ever known you know her only
sense of security i mean i never had to
never had to you know discipline this
little girl she just was she ate
everything i cooked she was just great
everybody loved her she was spoiled
rotten you know
no problems ever
and uh
yeah she just gets ripped out of her
home it's just crazy her mom had
actually kidnapped her and that's how i
found out that she was being molested
she kidnapped her like three minutes
later she calls me up oh can she come by
for the evening to spend the night or
whatever by the end of the conversation
she was back with me you know
and you know
and that was that she was back with me
she couldn't have her there because uh
whatever reason whatever excuse she gave
it was [ __ ] but
yeah so i had her back but then i
realized that she was being molested and
so you know of course i had
i felt like i was protecting her and so
i called cps and that was the worst
mistake i could have done
honestly i mean
i would have rather at this point
looking back that's one regret i have
that i would have taken i should have
just taken street justice on that
sob
because he didn't get charged nothing
and they ripped her out of my home
and
who knows what happened with her i don't
know they didn't keep in touch with me
nothing um
so it's
it's sad but you know that's that's the
way
the foster system is you know
has sex work continued on in your life
yes since since strip clubs yes and then
what in what form um you're still
beautiful so i can imagine you might
have sugar daddies and things like that
yeah i have some sugar daddies and
one or two that i like to keep you know
i've had one of them like 20 years they
take care of you yeah they take care of
me there you go yeah um i actually got
into
doing
porno after
i got into the car accident you know i
mean because i didn't you know didn't
have to be on my feet
so to speak so i got into that i
won an award for uh best newcomer in 93
for yeah so that was that was
interesting that was fun um
but yeah then i just started escorting i
figured you know
why not you know bringing again bringing
pleasure to somebody who is
unhappy with their current situation for
whatever reason and i'm bringing them
joy i mean there's an interesting
attitude to have about it yeah i mean
i've never been embarrassed about it
i've never been ashamed of it because
you know i figure i'm doing society a
favor and i'm sure i'm keeping rapists
from raping people and and
young men who are just frustrated from
going out and hurting people because
they can't get any kind of release and
they don't you know they're so inverted
or whatever reason you know they can't
talk to a girl on their own so you know
i mean
and i just you know i i've kept
regulars you know we call them regulars
and just people who are
my good friends you know i mean they
look out for me they take care of me and
you know
i've grown to love some of them you know
just like so you've been in love before
huh you've been in love before yes i've
been in love with a man and a woman
actually
you know so and
love is great you know
um i'm not i'm not choosing it just as
long as i know that you love me back
then
that's all i need you know
what of all these years doing various
kinds of sex work taught you about
about men or about relationships or
um
well again you know sex and sex and love
is love you know just because
you're in love with someone doesn't mean
you want to have sex with him or if you
know you cannot be in love with someone
and have sex with them you know
that's a big one um and basically
guys are going to pay for it one way or
another
it's a mutual agreement that way nobody
gets their feelings hurt and or feels
taken advantage of
i've heard someone
say that sex work for money is is
more honest than any other other form of
relationship well yeah yeah because you
know what's what you expect and what
you're getting and what you want out of
it and you know they're gonna there's no
front there they don't have to lie they
don't have to you know persuade you or
trick you into anything because it's
already
you know what we already know what's
going to happen there's many kinds of
relationships
yeah many kinds of relationships and
it's
it's uh
i'm not one to
actually
get real personal with someone like
right off the bat
i like to feel them out i never kiss i
never kiss people that's my one thing i
don't kiss
that to me is too intimate even someone
you love with you're in love with uh if
i'm in love with somebody yes i love
kissing yeah yeah but just not yours but
clients no
that's my one thing i will not you know
mean
i just don't like it i don't i just feel
it's too intimate it's you know it's a
business deal it's not
you know i mean even though a lot of
them end up becoming my friends
um you know so i still don't kiss him
you know what was what was the best
decade of your life can i ask how old
you are um i'm 49 49 what was the best
decade of your life
the best decade of my life um i would
say
[Music]
between
29 and 35
that's not a decade but
you know those those are the best times
i think for me
um i spent a lot of time in prison
my whole 20s basically
yeah
for narcotics and loaded firearms deadly
weapons things of that nature
and uh
i didn't do 11 straight years i did 11
years basically though because i'd be
out for three months or two months or a
day or you know and
i i like to say i was on a rotation
because i was always out like certain
times of the year like i seemed like i
was always out for summer and my
birthday and then i would go in
and then just do it all over again but
yeah 11 years
but back then
it's not like it is today because
actually i waited 10 years and i went
back in 2010 and i went back for 16
months
and that 16 months that i did
was the longest
and miserablest time than all the time i
did before the 10 years that i did
before
it was just miserable because
back when i started going to prison it
was actually kind of fun
you know we could smoke cigarettes we
could have our own clothes we got boxes
you know send in walkmans tvs such as
that you know and of course you know we
get a date so we're never going home
eventually and there's drugs in there
and lots of drugs in there to do and
some reason i was always uh one of my
homegirls was the one running the yard
with the dopes
i always walked out the gate strung out
literally uh
one time they shut the yard down because
i was in the bathroom getting high
instead of paroling
yeah that's how fun it was but
but the time i went in 2000 uh into in
2010 oh my god like it's changed so much
like it's gray and
gray shirts and denim jeans that you
know state issue only um
it was just miserable there's no no
tobacco anymore
um cigarettes have uh
have taken the place of heroin basically
um everybody's on medication rather than
heroin or anything illicit like that
yeah it's a lot different you know and a
lot of the youngsters there
a lot of lifers that are young
nowadays which is really kind of scary
um and these are female yeah females
yeah
um actually one of my first bunkies when
i went to prison was there before i was
born
yeah her name is miss andy who choose
from florida apparently she killed her
nephew uh she's passed on that since
then but yeah so your life of sex work
and drugs and prison and things like
that
is that
a product of
your something that happened in your
childhood or is it just product of being
a west virginian or one i think it's a
product of the fact that for one i was
molested by my grandfather um and the
fact that my mom just wasn't emotionally
there she just for whatever reason she
couldn't be you know i think
i think she did the best that she could
you know and with what she was given and
with what she's been dealing with i i
don't know if i could have lived her
life
and because she doesn't use anything she
drinks coffee she doesn't smoke
cigarettes she doesn't
drink alcohol she and she never did
um
i don't know if i could have done that
being in her shoes so i never i never
judge people because you never know
you'd like to think that you would act
and respond a certain way but you don't
know until you're in this that person's
shoes
how you're going to respond so you can
say oh i would i would do this or that
but you're bullshitting because you
don't know what you're going to do until
you're there you know and like i said i
don't know what i would do i don't i
don't think i could have lived her life
you mean honestly as much craziness as
i've lived through and
you know being in shootouts and
all kinds of stuff and
yeah her life that would that would have
killed me at being you know young and
married you got kids and take care of
and
just all that responsibility and you
know have another other lives to take
care of you know i mean and worry and be
concerned about but she did it she
didn't and you know brandon i think i
barely remember her having one job
in her life
one job the entire time she she was
smart about it she married the right man
i guess
that money
but um like i said when i was 13 she
just wanted to be with him because he
treated her good after she was with
the jerk for you know however many years
they were together um
so i just i think she felt like she was
doing the right thing and i thought i
think that
she felt that i would do the right thing
unfortunately at that age you know
what do we start partying that's perfect
time you know i think that's when you
need your parents the most about that
age you know
young teenager yeah 19 12 13 you know 14
definitely that's when you you know you
know everything you know nobody can tell
you anything because you already know
and everybody else is stupid you know
but you're just naive and and
not ready for
for what can be out there you know nancy
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
life um the most important lesson i've
learned is
never don't judge people
and
and try to always treat people the way
you want to be treated there's not
enough love in the world and there's
nothing wrong with being head over heels
in love with someone
it's really not you know too many people
are ashamed of that or embarrassed to
say
that you know they're head over heels in
love with someone because they feel like
it's weak or whatever reason it's not
enough love in the world you know and
people need to treat each other better
it's beautiful
nancy thank you so much for sharing your
story all right thank you
thank you
all right a little better this time
you